hey this is press tow
Walker if you didn't know Friday the
13th is considered an unlucky day in
Western
Superstition how bad is it an estimated
17 to 21 million people are affected by
fear on this day in the United States
making it the most feared day and date
in history this leads to an estimated $
800 to $900 million in Lost business now
why why are people scared of Friday the
13th your guess is as good as mine I was
reading the history in Wikipedia and
none of these explanations were
completely convincing to me regardless
if we accept that Friday the 13th is
considered unlucky you might start
looking Year bye when Friday the 13
happens it turns out that every single
year seems to have at least one Friday
the 13th if not up to three in fact we
will prove a mathematical fact every
year has at least one Friday the 13th
and a year has at most three Friday the
13th now let's just look at the calendar
of
20123 there are two Friday the 13
January 13th and October
13th so in order to do an analysis let's
first look at a non-leap here here's a
general calendar starting with January 1
on Sunday for a non-leap year we are
going to consider which days of the year
are the 13th of each month so start with
the 13th day of January this will be the
13th day of the
year now February 13 will be 31 days
later because January has 31 days so we
add 31 to get to the 44th day to figure
out March 13th we can add 28 days
because February has 28 days so 44 + 28
is equal to 72 then to get to April 13th
we have 31 days because March has 31
days so 72 + 31 is equal to
103 it's a simple arithmetic exercise to
figure out which day of the year is the
13th of each month so we'll just go
ahead and do these calculations for each
of the 12
months so now we have an absolute number
for which day the 13th of the month is
so let's just go ahead and label
that we now need to convert these
absolute numbers into days of the week
so we'll notice that a week has seven
days so the days of the week repeat
every seven days day 1 8 1522 and so on
will be the same day of the week days 2
9623 and so on will also be the same day
of the week so if we can remove
multiples of seven we can figure out
which day of the week each of these
belongs to so we will look at the
remainder by seven or module of seven of
each of these numbers so day 13 13 / 7
is equal to 1 remainder 6 44 ID 7 is
equal to 6 remainder two we just want
the remainders so day 133 will be six 44
will be two and we can continue now 72
is two more than a multiple of seven so
that'll be two and we calculate each of
these remainders by seven or we take
each number modulo
7 each remainder represents a different
day of the
week all seven remainders going from 0
to six are represented so each day of
the week is the 13th day in some month
therefore at least one month has a
Friday 13th furthermore look at the most
common remainder which is two this
happens three times therefore the
maximum number of months that have a
Friday the 13th is three so we've proven
that in a non-leap year there will
always be a Friday the 13th and we can
have at most three of
them we just need to do the same
calculation leap year so in a leap year
February has 29 days so we'll go ahead
and calculate the 13th of each month the
13th of January will be day 13 the 13th
of February will be 13 + 31 which is 44
now to get to March 13th we have to add
29 more days so this will be different
from the previous calculation now we go
ahead and figure out the 13th day of
each month for the rest of the months in
the year this will just be one more than
in a non-leap year so we figure out the
13th day of the month for each of the 12
months we now go ahead and convert this
into days of the week so we take the
remainder by seven or moduo 7 and we
analyze these results so once again each
remainder represents a different day of
the week all seven remainders are
represented and therefore at least one
month has a Friday the 13th and again at
most three of the remainders are the
same so we can have a maximum of three
Friday the 13th in a
year so while people in fear may want to
avoid Friday the 13th it's a
mathematical fact that it will happen
every year and it can happen at most
three
times thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
[Music]
time
o